alice first of all welcome back to the
show welcome back uh to saint louis we
haven't seen you since the american cup
how does it feel to be back uh it's
great to be back here st louis is just
like it's so nice here and it's just one
of my favorite places to be
what were your ambitions coming into
this event because we know how well you
did in the american cup
did you want to win this event uh well
that was certainly the higher goal
although um my goal now is just to do
better than i did last year
well a difficult start for you two
losses in uh the first four games but
finally you broke through let's go uh
through today's game okay
tell us your critical moments in your
opinion
oops uh
i think that
the main
turning point was
when she allowed knight c5 to d3
um
that was
later
um
yeah so i'm not i wasn't sure about the
opening but i thought that it went okay
um i was able to
sort of get her to develop her knight to
d2 before taking on d4 because usually
she wants to do like c64 and um and get
the knight to c3
yeah so
um
i made some weighty moves um
that are kind of useful just to
make her kind of move her night before i
take on d4
and she did and you timed it well and
now were you uh surprised by this move
knight to f3 and how quickly did you
spot this knight c5 knight d3 id uh yeah
so i was planning uh knight c5 to d3 um
with queen a6 like i think that was my
main threat before she played knight f3
because i can't do e5 as it runs into
knight f5
um and then i should be much worse
so if you don't have the knight on f3
yeah yes
um so
after she allowed this uh i thought that
here i should kind of be winning because
like i'm going to win some material and
i don't see that she has too much
compensation
excellent let's keep going and i really
like this move
bishop to a3
did you see it from afar no i was
thinking here like what i should do i
thought like maybe bishop takes e5 maybe
bishop e7 or bishop c5
um
so i would be up in exchange but i
thought it would be cleaner to play
bishop a3 after i saw the move
because um now
my pawn structure won't be too much
worse than hers like
i was expecting btx a3 in which case i
play knight d5 and there's not a too
easy of a way for her to get to my pawns
but
now i'm trying to play work day c3 takes
a3 and um also win the a2 pawn and that
should be winning also
and after that it felt like the
conversion
was quite easy alice congratulations
your first victory in the tournament a
rest day is coming up what are you going
to do during the rest day um i guess
kind of mentally
prepare for the next four rounds
i think i'll be playing salia
as white it's a big game yeah
hopefully i'll be able to end well
alice congratulations uh for today and
we're looking forward to see you in the
rest of your games thank you